to be not focused on race seems to be
considered in itself racist now which i
think is
insane
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantin kissing and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our brilliant guest today is a writer
editor and podcaster she's a sub-editor
of ariel magazine
iona natalie welcome to trigonometry
thank you it's great to have you here
uh before we get into the the
conversation uh which we
really look forward to tell us a little
bit about who are you
how are you where you are what has been
the journey through life that brings you
here
um so i um
grew up in pakistan uh in the parsi
community my father was
an indian-born parsi who moved to
pakistan in the 60s
my mother was scottish and then i moved
here to the uk
in my early teens and i went to
school here and university i did
a phd in english literature and i was an
academic um
until 2006 when for some unknown reason
i decided to leave academe and go and
live in buenos aires and teach
tango and for about 11 years
i danced tango i taught tango and i had
a very popular
tango blog and so i would also
tour and give readings and advice and
things
and i've since made that blog into
into two books on tango and then i
went to india for two years 2017
to 2019 and i've begun work on a
new book which is memoirs
and little biographies of mixed race
indians
and in the meantime i
switched when i when i went to india i
knew that i wouldn't be able to just
to teach tango for a living full-time
anymore
so i switched over to becoming
a an editor i met helen pluck rose
online and i got involved with ariel
and in later i got involved with a
company called lecher wiki who do
public lecture exchanges between people
and i recently also joined the team at
yasha monk's
new publication which is called
persuasion
so i reinvented myself a few years ago
about
three and a half years ago as a
writer editor and then i moved to
london in march of this year good timing
on purpose actually i was planning to
move in the summer
yeah but i suddenly realized that i
if i didn't leave right then i was
unlikely to be able to go
i found it interesting you talked about
your journey from you know buenos aires
to
bombay to london and in that time i've
moved from south london to
north london to east london so there we
go it's a slightly different journey
um but it's interesting you talk about
the book you're working on now which is
uh about mixed-race indians the whole
conversation about race that we're
certainly having in the western world i
don't know whether it's happening in the
same way in india
but you can tell us uh but but it's it
seems to have gone in some sort of
interesting direction to put it very
mildly what are your sort of thoughts on
it
um i have a few thoughts i mean one
thing i think is that there has been
this
absolute obsession with racism
and detecting racism everywhere
and i don't want to imply that racism
doesn't
occur and isn't important but it goes on
this set all
the time mainly against me yeah we don't
like russians
well you know who can blame you
and you said you weren't funny there was
no there we go yeah we don't let him
make the tea
anyway sorry i near i nearly i nearly
brought a jar of marmite
hate speech right there hey actions
literal violence i don't want to be
actually thrown off the set
yeah so i refrained well yes we are
obsessed with racism
uh everywhere and you're not saying it
doesn't exist
i think that this folk this continual
focus on um the race elements of things
this
we're continually asking not is this
uh is this particular phenomenon
affecting people badly
um are there people in need we should uh
help but we
we always ask well um
which people of which race does it
affect in what proportions
there's this kind of racial bean
counting that goes on all the time
which i think is extremely unhelpful and
i think that might be one of the reasons
why bernie sanders wasn't successful in
the us
elections um in the in the u.s
primaries is that he was talking about
things that would
um he was largely talking about measures
that would benefit
everybody who was in need
so for example universal healthcare but
that wouldn't
that weren't framed in terms of
specifically
and primarily benefiting black americans
and that seems some people seem to have
seen that
in itself as racist that it wasn't
focused to be not
focused on race seems to be considered
in itself racist now which i think is
insane have you seen it grown worse
over the years this sort of focus on
race
i think so um
i feel as though it's been since about
since about 2009 2010
there's been a there's been this shift
in focus from a kind of
liberal way of looking at things
from concern with
poverty hardship etc to this
much more identity based identity
conscious
way of analyzing and looking at the
world and
um i find it mostly extremely unhelpful
i mean i think it's it can be
it can be positive and fun to celebrate
your ethnic identity or your race quote
unquote
if you enjoy that but
i don't find it helpful to be constantly
asking
well what do i think of this person's
opinion
first i need to know what race they are
and then i can decide whether it's worth
listening to them on this topic
or not before i know whether this
particular policy is a good idea i need
to know
what are the skin colors the people that
affect most effects
and i saw that with things like the
grenfell tower
disaster that was such an obvious
tragedy and to me the important things
were
the shoddy building the poor housing the
poverty
but everybody started focusing on how
many
people brown and black skin are living
in the tower
as opposed to white people and i just
feel that that is
extremely unimportant and what and why
do you feel it's unimportant ayanna
so if let's say bangladeshis
um as who as a community i think
are over-represented in prison
under-represented in
um high-paying jobs etc so let's say
if we can help people who are poor
and who have who live in
food deserts who have poor housing who
have poor access to education
that will disproportionately help this
group because they are
disproportionately represented there
we don't need to target it at them
specifically
and i think it's it it is
um it's divisive so
i hear all of this rhetoric
from both right and left about the white
working class
but brown and black people are
disproportionately represented in the
working class
and to me what is important is the
working working-class issues not
not this kind of racial division i
couldn't agree with you more
i think the reason people talk about the
white working class is that
um while there's been a focus recently
on
sort of black and brown people and
making sure that they
they're getting the support that they
need not nonsense i'm not saying they're
getting it but there's certainly been a
focus on it
um there seems to be that group of
people who are somewhat ignored
and i think that's where you start to
get this disparity and as you say
that's the reason for that is that it's
divisive this way of looking at things
is divisive and then it forces everybody
to go well what about me what about my
race what about this
instead of just all of us going we we
need to support people who are
who are low income or who have a poor
education or who live in terrible
housing that can
combust in flames and kill hundreds of
people
um and you but you mentioned bernie
sanders which i thought was interesting
because what you're really saying there
and it's a very good observation is that
his message would have appealed to the
broader american public
but he couldn't get through the
primaries because within his party
an agenda that appeals to everybody is
considered
insufficiently woke you might say yes
which seems to be a sort of
contradiction in terms because the
objective of political party by
definition is to win power
and yet what they're really doing is
this they've ended up with a candidate
who would best respect him and we don't
like to make fun of him
you know he's he's not in his best years
let's say
he's not in the prime of his health or
whatever so
they've ended up with a candidate that's
certainly inferior in many ways
simply because of a sort of ideological
obsession with that would you agree with
that
yes yes um and i do think that this
i i think that this constant focus on
race
makes people very self-conscious and
awkward
and it is actually damaging to people's
interactions and it is
if anything it's going to make people
more racist
because people are fixating on this
aspect of identity and i think that is
very
dangerous it's an interesting thing
because there's almost like a
self-fulfilling prophecy about it
because if you
if you say well there's so much racism
and therefore we need to focus on race
and then you create the races and then
you go look i told you there was racism
i think
james lindsay uh helen's colleague made
this point when we had him on the show
the first time is that like it never
stops when
when if trump let's say gets reelected
that will only be used as evidence that
more wokeness is needed
because people will go look how much
racism there is as opposed to
recognizing
their role in it so what what do you
think would be a
healthy solution what do you advise
people to do
in in terms of having this conversation
well we we need to get beyond race as
much as we possibly can
so i think that if ever you're tempted
to say
this white person said x and y or this
black person said x and y
just try removing the word white or
black from that
try to deal with people as individuals
try to focus on their opinions as
individuals
try to look at it with as little focus
on races
as possible i mean i understand that
you're saying that but is that going to
be possible in our society now don't you
think we've gone so far down the path
that it's
it's going to be so tricky to roll back
from that i hope i hope we can roll back
from that
i think that i mean i feel that the
helpful things are
um a civic conception of nationalism
i i hope that this topic might become
moot
in the west because there is um
there has been so much racial mixing
quote unquote
because to talk about people's mixed
race implies that there is some
purity there are some people who are
pure which obviously doesn't really
it doesn't make sense but in a kind of
colloquial sense
there is um there are so many more
mixed-race people
now and when i interviewed eric kaufman
who's recently written a book called
white shift
eric if eric's demographic projections
are correct
by 2100
the west will be 90 percent mixed race
but of course many of those people will
no longer think of themselves as
as mixed race but they will uh many of
them will think of themselves as white
this is eric's
argument just like uh um hispanics and
latino immigrants to the us
the first and second generation usually
think of themselves as
latino and they tick that box on the
census but by the third generation
onwards
they think they think of themselves as
white american and they tick that box
look at francis he's so progressive he's
the second generation he thinks he's
white
yeah absolutely he pretends to be white
but it's it's and there's a question
that i wanted to ask you is that
you obviously half you so you're half
indian half scottish
yeah and there's something there's
there's something that i discuss with
people who come from a mixed background
and that and i'd be interested to see
what you think of that in that you never
truly feel that you belong anywhere
in a way because you are always other
you never truly so half infarm half
english of venezuelan
i was raised by my mother my mother
raised me and my father was always
working so
she raised me very much in the
traditional latino sense
which means that i view the world
differently like
i have different values in a way from a
lot of my english friends he's a great
lover
yeah exactly you would not now
now that means that i feel a sort of
detachment almost
from i'm never truly english i'm never
truly venezuelan do you feel that and do
you feel that there is an issue around
that
i think that there's um there's kind of
two ways that it can go
um i feel that being mixed race can be a
kind of
opportunity um
to build bridges and
um defy labels and
um and and show how kind of superficial
and silly
uh such labels are and
it can also it can also give you this
kind of
sense of disorientation
and i certainly being parsley in
particular
being parsley is like identity politics
on
steroids because
so parsley identity is patrilineal if
your mother was parsi
you are not parsi um if you married a
parsi
uh pers if you married a parsi person
you are not parsi and
if you are the adopted child of a of a
parsi father you're not parsley it's
absolutely strict
in this extremely um
extremely inhumane way so there was
recently a court case
uh where um the two
daughters of a parsi mother wanted to go
to the
funerary ceremonies that the sky burials
which we famously have where you were
eaten by vultures
which is my my dream for after death
if anybody's to be eaten by volcanoes
we've all got to have dreams
but she was not they were not allowed to
go to the
their mother's funeral because
only um parsees can enter the dungarwagi
which is the funerary
um gardens and grounds in
um in bombay um it doesn't sound very
inclusive
no it's not inclusive at all
where's the progressive weather it's not
very woke
no not very woke it's absolutely not
inclusive at all and you can't
um so there are many uh parsi
uh you can't go to the fire temples um
and we also have these holy wells
in bombay and you cannot enter unless
you are a parsi
and i did get questioned uh sometimes
because i don't
look especially part i don't look very
indian
um although parsees are also paler skin
than most
other indians and more western looking
but occasionally i was questioned but as
soon as i said
my father's name i was allowed in
because my father was parsi
so when you're parsley i feel as though
you're constantly having
i was constantly having to prove my
identity
and i always felt a bit because my
father died when i was quite young
and my gujarati parsisol speak gujarati
is very very rusty almost non-existent
and because i
grew up largely in the uk so i
um there are a lot of prayers that
you're supposed to be able to say by
heart and i can't
um most of them i can't say i can't
remember by heart
there's all kinds of ritual actions
you're supposed to do and
um you're supposed to know what uh
what date it is in the zoroastrian
calendar and
is it a fire day a water day or whatever
uh so i always i always feel a bit
nervous uh about proving who i am
and in india it's vital i lived in the
parsi bargain for that you have to be a
party only parties can stay there
um ones if you identify as parsley
well i think that you should if i feel
as though everybody should be able to do
what they want
if you i i'm completely in favor of both
transgender people and i think trans
racialism should be fine
if you feel like you really identify
with japanese culture and you just want
to
be japanese i think you should be able
to be or really
yes i do um hold on let's
let's zero in on that because this
suddenly got interesting for me so
if i identify as japanese
if you want i mean japanese people
should have to pretend that i'm japanese
should have to pretend
no okay but i think that
authenticity is really a myth
um i think it's a it's a beautiful myth
to imagine on
on the father's side my ancestors going
back
landing on the coast of gujarat in the
8th century and before that
being part of the sassanid empire in
persian etc
it's there's something very moving and
beautiful by that but it's
also it really is it really is myth
it's not um there isn't some kind of
parsy infusion in my dna somewhere
so i feel that if you want to
convert to zoroastrianism you should be
able to and if you want to go to
and do the parsy ceremonies and become a
parsi
you should be able to see i don't know
much about the party identity which is
why i'm
slightly disadvantaged here but you gave
the japanese example
so i japanese is not being japanese is
not a religious thing
it's not right you can convert to
judaism or to christianity or to
islam and and you can then be part of
that identity but
i don't think me being interested in
japanese
my sister for example is massively into
japanese culture speaks very
good japanese but she'll never be
japanese
well i i um i probably i'm really
thinking of
um could you be a kind of master of some
traditional japanese art
sure form um like kintu sorai
the one where they do the the cracked
put gold into the cracks in the pottery
or um could you be a shinto priest
or something like that i i would say
that you should be able to be
oh sure either does that make you
japanese i guess is what i'm getting
that
because you see you said translation
right maybe not so that's
more what i'm thinking of when i'm
thinking of a kind of trans-racial
identity
so there is your actual parentage yeah
which you can't change yeah
unfortunately yeah you should
pick your parents more carefully exactly
but there's also the kind of kind of
ethnic connection to a culture which i
think should be
uh you should be able to choose in the
same ways you can't change your sex
um but you can but you should be able to
change your gender if you want to live
as the opposite
as the opposite gender in society you
should be able to do that
so i feel similarly about both those
things there
is the um there is the actual
your actual ancestry and your biology
which it doesn't make sense to lie about
and um if you are trying to pretend that
you are someone
you are not that is obviously a very
brittle fragile situation
but then there is the culture that you
identify with
the behavior that you identify with the
way that you want to be seen
and i think that those things you should
be able to choose as widely as possible
language is obviously part of it and we
we've touched on it now
but you wrote a very very interesting
article where you talked about
boris johnson and his use of language
and you've also
discussed widely you know the effect
language has on us you've used examples
like jordan peterson
can you just delve a little bit into why
you think language is important and our
use of language particularly when it
comes to people eventual influence like
your boris johnson's
your donald trumps or in fact you're
jordan peterson's
uh maybe i can start with this this
isn't so much about trump
and johnson but one thing that i've
noticed
in the kind of shift from this sort of
more
liberal politics to more woke identity
politics style
approach which i was talking about which
i feel happened
at the end of the arts in around kind of
2008
910 um i
that's that's a totally subjective
evaluation
but that's when i feel it began to
really shift over
and i think that one thing that happened
is
that wokeness encourages
and it's worse it encourages this kind
of paranoia
it's everything must be re-examined to
see what it really means
and as a result i've noticed that
people's writing has
and speech has just gotten much worse
because and of course i'm generalizing
wildly here
but people have become begun hedging
absolutely everything so
their writing has become more and more
and it's
it's really hard for any
academics have always written badly but
it's got worse and worse it's really
hard for them to say
anything in a simple clear way and
i've noticed also that there's been a
lot of
kind of sloganeering
and we are expected to
to know the thing that is being said
isn't what is actually meant
so um for i i think the most
egregious example of this was a couple
of years ago with sarah jong
who wrote all these tweets about how
much she hated white people
one of them said i really
love to see old white men suffer
something like that and there was a huge
scandal about this
and her employers at the new york times
and
other people on the social justice left
defended her
tweets on the grounds that when she said
things like that it was actually code
for
i would like to see a less racist more
racially egalitarian society
so there's this kind of extraordinary
on the one hand hyper examination
of language which has just seems to have
disabled some people from being able to
say anything comprehensible
and on the other hand there's there are
all these kind of
codes and um there's also this
this kind of this concept of trolling
which is something you see on the trump
right as well as on the left
i see this happening on both sides of
the spectrum where
oh well i said this thing but it was um
i'm kind of wait
i will say the thing like i want old
white men to suffer
and i'm going to wait to see how it's
received
and if it's received badly then i'm
going to pretend i was just joking
to begin with sounds like our routine
but actually i mean that is part of
comedy in the sense that you never
really know whether something's funny
until you've said it a few times and
you've seen the response so
you're trying to gauge the reaction and
if the reaction is not good
then you probably don't want to say that
thing again but
it's interesting talk about academia
because it seems to me that some
academia and
your colleague and boss at ariel
helen placer my captain your captain
uh see words are important um
with uh peter bogossian and james
lindsey
they kind of established that a lot of
modern academia particularly in the
social sciences
is actually not just it's not hedging
it's obscurantism it's where
you're deliberately not saying anything
but you're saying it in a way that no
one else can tell that you're not saying
anything
and so there's been a lot of that as
well hasn't that absolutely
i think it's really telling that
um there's been at the same time as
as um the
the so-called squared hoax the hoax that
helen james and
peter did uh came to light
there's also been a replication crisis
in psychology in particular but in
science more generally
and for people who don't who are not
academic let's just explain replication
crisis essentially means that
you pretend that something is true but
no one else can reproduce the
quote-unquote experiment that got you
the quote-unquote results
because really most of it is [ __ ]
let's just call it what it is right
a lot of so in psych there are a lot of
classic experiments
which supposedly prove certain things
about character
so one famous one is the marshmallow
experiment where they gave children
two marshmallows or they gave them a
marshmallow i think yes they gave them a
marshmallow
and they were told um
you can either eat the marshmallow now
or if you wait 10 minutes you can get a
second marshmallow
and then you eat them together but the
point is you can't eat the first one
until 10 minutes have elapsed
exactly and then they followed the kids
in later life
and they claimed there was a correlation
between
um the children who were able to resist
eating the first marshmallow
and they had video of them it was very
cute some were like
looking away like this trying not to see
and and a couple of them picked up
sniffed it licked it
back down yeah it was adorable but um
apparently there was a correlation
between being able to resist eating the
second marshmallow for 10 minutes
and being successful in later life
and this is one of the psych experiments
that was cited
a lot and a lot of other work was based
on it
yeah and um and and it
hasn't replicated you're breaking my
heart here i've been quoting that
experiment all the time about the
importance of being able to wait
really it hasn't replicated see this is
why we need we need the fake science so
people like me can feel good
yeah um so this this this this
experiment has been essentially debunked
or at least can't be reproduced
it can't be reproduced which means that
it they haven't proved
anything so we don't know whether it
worked or
not no and that's now true with a huge
number of experiments in psych
and some that are really well known but
there's also replication crisis
more broadly in science and i've been
reading stuart ritchie's
book about that you should have him on
this podcast
he is also here in london
but with a replication crisis in science
when people when the whistleblower
showed that things were not replicating
um the people in psych have are all
expressing concern
um making changes doing reforms
and the so-called square hoax
which showed that if you have a kind of
woke political slant on your paper you
can publish
all kinds of absolute [ __ ] well in
their case
they published a chapter from mind camp
yeah rewrote it with some intersectional
language
and they were able to get it into
magazine yeah just
published it there's a reason it's a
bestseller mate
and when this came out you know what's
happened is that
all of um all of the academics are are
circling the wagons they're all very
angry i mean not all
but everybody who's almost everyone
who's responding to it is responding to
it
in this angry way with personal attacks
on them
and complete denial it's just the
contrast between how people in psycho
reacting to the much worse crisis in
their field
and how people are responding to the the
publication
is these hoax papers is just
extraordinary
and why why do you say why do you say
it's extraordinary
because there should really be a wake-up
call
um it should um
it it should be a wake-up call
for the fact that um number of
publications has nothing about the
quality of your
work especially in arts and humanities
academy
that your work in social sciences
shouldn't be whether or not the work is
publishable shouldn't be dependent on
your
political stance it's also
worrying that almost everybody in
social sciences and humanities is
almost all the faculty are left-wing and
i say that as a left-wing person myself
i would expect most people to be
left-wing in academe but not
80 to 1. um and
i think that um i think that there are
so many concerns there that that have
been highlighted by
the success of the hoax and there are
things that we
already knew in fact but the hoax has
just
made it more undeniable
and it should be a reason for people to
be re-examining how they are doing
things
but is it no surprise people don't like
to change the mind i'm still going to
believe in the marshmallow experiment
but you talk about being left-wing and
maybe we've got a little bit of time
left so i
want to perhaps finish on that um
it's interesting isn't it because
there's a small portion i would argue of
the left
has gone sort of crazy uh and
i think a lot of the other people on the
left are sort of tarnished by
association
uh even if they are reasonable and
sensible and saying as you are
so why are you left-wing um
i well i'm a kind of old-fashioned
um from each according to their ability
and to each according to
um wait according to their need i i seem
to remember that slogan from russian
history
sounds familiar um i mean i'm obviously
i'm not a marxist communism is a failed
system incompatible with human nature we
need capitalism for wealth
generation but i think that
we could do a lot more to
prevent the people who are most
struggling in society
from living in real hardship
and whether that is through social
security or through
ubi um i think that we
we have the means to do that and it
would create
a more peaceful and harmonious society
for everybody
including those who are better off of
course the devil is in the details but i
think that we are not
we're not going far enough in that
direction you know on that thing
something that francis and i often talk
about
is that do you think that one of the
challenges for the same left is
that there is a sort of trend on the
left and this is again a broad
generalization which we're trying to
stay away from
to ignore the human nature as you yes
you referenced when you talked about
communism so
for example when we talk about uh people
who are
currently uh not very privileged let's
say they don't have
access to a law right part of the reason
for that might be is the by by nature of
their sort of genetic
and uh other background so part of this
genetic part of is the education part of
their family background maybe they come
from a home where they didn't get a lot
of attention when they were a kid
it would be difficult for them always
through life to to have a a comfortable
life that will always be a challenge for
them right
but if you think that uh any bad
outcomes
are the product of structural inequality
uh then you'll never actually look at
that and you'll never accept that some
some group of people will always need
help by virtue of the fact
that that's just the way they are you
know is that do you think uh
am i right to point at that as a sort of
gap in in people's thinking
um i think so i mean i definitely don't
think human beings are
infinitely malleable i think we're a lot
less malleable than
[Music]
than most people on the left usually say
i'm actually a non-believer in free will
so i think it's all luck
all the way down
and um so yes i think that
we um will never achieve kind of
equality of outcome um
what we can do is try to give a quality
of opportunity
as far as possible and provide a safety
net
so that people no one is is really
or as few people as possible are living
in misery
so and i think that safety net can
actually be
raised a bit um so
i yeah i'm not really
i think that looking at outcomes is also
the wrong way to go about things
trying to tinker with outcomes to say oh
we don't have enough
i don't know we don't have enough people
of pakistani origin playing in our
orchestra
i don't find that a useful way of
looking at things at all
you give opportunities and then you have
to live with the fact that people will
um people will end up even
when opportunities are completely equal
with differences in outcome
and they're liable to be differences
between groups
um there is i mean life is complicated
there are a lot of steps between
opportunity and
achievement but isn't the problem as
well especially in the uk that we have
this class system so we talk about
equality of opportunity
but the reality is if that you come from
a working class background you're simply
not going to get
the range of opportunity that you would
do if you went to a
highly exclusive public school and you
know grew up in a wonderful area of
london etc etc
yeah absolutely um i mean many of my
friends bought their first houses or
flats
with help from their parents and that
made a huge difference to them
and that difference has continued to the
present day
when we're now in our 50s so yeah i
don't think we're ever gonna have
equality but we can we can make it
easier
for people who haven't come from an
affluent background
well i went to boarding school me too
and here i am
honestly working with someone who went
who didn't
go to boarding school for a long time he
was from a sort of working-class
background
exactly and look at what a better person
you've become as a result of this he's
now kind he's compassionate
my po where's my privilege this is my
privilege
did you did you enjoy your boarding
school because my boarding school was
like a cross between prison and the army
yeah well the thing is with i i i
i'd agree with that description but the
thing is the army can be good for some
people
as well so it depends on the sort of
person that you are i find it more
difficult from a sort of adapting
because when i came i didn't speak any
english so i found it quite difficult to
fit in initially
but then i found the great thing about
boarding school
is it gives you the opportunity to find
things that you're good at and do a lot
of them
and so i got the opportunity to try my
hand at lots of things and be bad at
lots of them
but then find some things that i was
good at you know
and then once that happened i i really
started to enjoy
a lot um but anyway i want my privilege
i want my privilege give it back to me
anyway i honestly it's been like great
chatting with you um
as always at the very end we ask uh one
final question
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
okay i think we should institute um ubi
universal basic income so
um i know some people are talking about
that but not enough
andrew yang was talking about it look
where that got him
i know but i was a fan of andrea so
let's talk about that more is there any
evidence that it's a good idea
in terms of practical experiments i
think that there have been
um there was an experiment in finland
and it was um i think it was too small
to be conclusive but it
went well well i think what that one
showed is people are not more likely to
go back to work if they are unemployed
because the people
were unemployed but they're a bit
happier yeah they're happier and in the
capital system we don't give a [ __ ]
about that too
so maybe that's the thing we should be
talking about more yeah
i mean i think that we
we think of success in terms of making
money
yes being well known and we don't value
things like
looking after your aged parents
we don't value looking after people who
are ill
we don't value family life we don't
value
time with your friends we don't value
people's creative pursuits
unless they're unless they're unusually
successful in them but
we are um we value
we value finances and it's supposedly a
successful life to be
ceo of a company working god knows how
what ours
um and i think that what is actually
valuable in life
is what how we
affect each other how we make each
other's lives better
so it may be a more valuable life to
just
be somebody who brightens up your
friends lives and your
family's life um than someone who is
making a lot of money
and obviously we do need money this is
the system
that we live in but i think that if we
if we could institute ubi if we had
better
safety nets some people would be able to
pursue things that
they can't currently pursue but which
are very worthwhile
because we only have one go around on
this planet
that's a lovely way of putting it so
iona thank you very much for coming on
the show if people want to follow you
where would that be or look or see your
work or read your work
um they can follow me on twitter at iona
italia
um you can find my work at ariel a-r-e-o
magazine and i have a website iona
iona italia.com and
um also check out my podcast which is
called
juforty perfect thank you so much for
coming on
thank you and thank you for watching we
will see you very soon with another live
stream
or episode all of them go out 7pm uk
time
uh the only time the only day we're not
broadcasting is mondays
so enjoy your mondays off and we'll see
you very soon take care guys
and see you next week or see you for
another fantastic
episode or live stream
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on itunes and spread the word